hello dad
there are signs to remind his dad he's
not safe to leave home alone but still
keith worries dad
dad it's keith
len has dementia he's been found
wandering the streets several times over
the last few years
but now he has a gps tracker it means
keith can see where he is and gets a
message alert if he wanders too far
well that's much much better than having
some
um kind stranger ringing me off and say
your father's wandering down the street
yes of course it is it's a vast
improvement
um
matt concerns me more than where how far
he goes he's in fact he's going to be
wandering across roads
um
injuring himself possibly causing
accidents
i can then relax a bit more
the police can also track the device
it's one of 30 that the avon and
somerset force have been giving to
people most at risk
the officer in charge of it decided
something had to be done we're getting
more and more calls to people who've got
dementia who are being fined by members
of the public either lost or in a
distressed state and there's certain
incidents i've attended as well that
have stuck with me some have ended up in
tragic circumstances and others
where
people living with dementia have
traveled across cities
to try and find childhood homes that are
no longer there so it was these sorts of
incidents
that led me to
look into a solution to this to better
safeguard people
he's already been contacted by forces
across the country keen to manage a
growing concern it's thought around 70
of people living with dementia may go
missing at least once with some at risk
of going missing many times
around 900 000 people in the uk have
dementia and that's predicted to rise
sharply to 1.6 million by 2040. it's
really important that we look at new
ways of helping people and supporting
them keeping them safe and so innovative
technology like this initiative are
really important in helping to do that
there are some ethical considerations
and there should always be some really
clear guidelines around how this kind of
technology is used particularly for
people who are
lacking capacity to make decisions for
themselves some biscuits for you you're
liking chocolate biscuits don't you but
technology could provide more families
with reassurance and allow people with
dementia to enjoy more independent lives
becky johnson sky news porter's head